oh yes my paycheck yes I only started  savings account pay rent on time and  maybe buy a new jacket for once hello  Milo hi okay hey can I give you a call  back 10 extra hours per week at the job  plus the minimum student loan payment  equals me paying them off in 43 years  cool hello are you calling me from a  different number girls one at nine  hundred dollars a night must be in the  foot stuff alright let me ask you a  question what's your name is a Brenda  it's a nice name my grandmother's name  did you ever have student loans or how  do you sleep at night  Brenda how do you sleep at night you're  a mobster no I don't have any money I  can't afford to pay you five dollars is  too much that's ridiculous  hello hi returned from an alma mater  would you like to make a donation to the  school are you serious aloma hey baby  your nephew got into college whoa don't  worry on a full-ride scholarship oh well  that's great cuz ma'am yay college